[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of off the record where
we got the careful boys here featuring
cat hey
thank you cat here i'm not a careful
girl i'm a careful boy too yeah she got
the biggest dick in the room do you have
a huge dick yeah because i feel like
that's the only way i can do this and
feel no no no you should not feel
pressured to feel anything about phantom
dicks or anything like if you choose i
just feel like this is the only like
safe place for me to do enough oh okay
cool
i feel like this is the only place i can
do it you're right you give the wrong
impression like people who come here
have to pretend they have a penis
you fit in better than some other i do
you fit in better than some guys that's
been here in the past
smart
swan
bart swan
bert swan
bert swan burt swan sounds like a [ __ ]
that guy he probably has nosebleeds all
the time bart looks more like a bird
than a bark
that's so insulting to tell somebody
you look like a bart
dude bursting more like a cat than a cat
bert's want only dms married ladies
[Laughter]
[ __ ] tricky
is there a bird swan in the world swan
walks out of the bathroom with tp on a
shoe
this guy's name is burt swan
are you serious yeah that guy looks cool
he looks cool okay all right
burt swans are certifiably cooler than
bart quan just wim hof dude
speaking of bert swan dude nikki [ __ ]
won world series of poker night speaking
of the sad the fourth fourth place
as far as her first tournament she
practically won the whole [ __ ] thing
yeah dude it was up against five
thousand five thousand seven hundred
people that's crazy nicki came in four
only rookie of the year yeah crazy it's
not main event yet so like during the
world series it's like a couple month
event and it starts um and and you can
do all these different satellite games
whatever but they're big like there's
like high roller tournaments where the
entry fee is 100 grand yeah it's crazy
very classy you got a buddy who's who's
doing that even damn man that's my name
nicky because uh aren't you uh aren't
you mr nikki
how does this tv
how does it feel like
to do
absolutely nothing but then get the uh
absolutely all the glory it's incredible
you're a hot girl that's what you are
yeah exactly yeah i'm a hot ass you're
true because people congratulate you on
behalf of nikki right oh yeah it's been
hilarious honestly this watching this
all happened has been one of the
funniest things i've ever been part of
because seeing nikki go
from the commerce casino a year ago
where she was like nervous because that
was like her first time like playing the
pros and stuff to like now she just
final table world series and came in
fourth she had 116 000 jackpot [ __ ]
crazy that's so good and yeah like i
said she started playing tournaments
four months ago because tournaments are
so different than playing regular cash
games yeah different kind of styles of
play how does how does the tournament
work it's more aggressive it's like
go ahead turn uh tournament you just pay
a fee and then you could do re-buys and
stuff like that but it's timed and then
it's elimination so at the end the pot
that everybody pulled together it's kind
of concentrated at the top whereas if
you play a cash game it's unlimited you
just keep buying it's just like guys at
a poker table and as long as there's
people sitting there you can play and
it's not like a knockout game yeah
so that's the difference yeah i would i
would remember i would take her to the
commerce and then just like obviously
want to be there just because commerce
is kind of crazy sometimes especially
when you're leaving at night so i would
just walk her like like
from the car and stuff because the
camera's kind of weird
um but it's like you're a pimp
you kind of feel like it yeah
no but it was dude watching her win
because she
the funniest thing too is that everyone
who knows nicki right you think about
like tasty tuesday or you think about
her on like podcasting like on jk and
big mood but you don't think that she's
like [ __ ] a poker shark yeah but she
has high level working so hard behind
the scenes like hours and hours and
hours and hours like doing poker
simulations and all kinds of [ __ ] like
she's been
non-stop pokering like like every day
and i've so i've seen the work that goes
into it but you know i understand like
for most people like who are watching or
like they know her on camera yeah she's
like baking making food but in behind
the scenes
she'll cut your [ __ ] throat seriously
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] so funny so you
know people who know us but like don't
necessarily hang out with us every day
like people like timmy d right who's
like he's seeing this [ __ ] and like
david was just texting me yesterday and
he they're like who the [ __ ] is your
wife dude
because it's like nobody thought this
but then i'm the one who's the least
surprised because i'm like dude i see
this [ __ ] working this [ __ ] oh she's
doing it for real though cuz i got deep
into it
and in a in a matter of a year
she went way surpassed what i did like i
was doing it very casually i got into it
a little bit
um and then like i was like you know it
got kind of ruined because um our poker
group
got [ __ ] up but
in what what nikki was doing he's gonna
gloss over that one
just yeah so in my quick story in my
poker group right
we would go together religiously we were
grinding it out we were going to all the
casinos and card rooms in california we
were playing like 48 hour days it was
[ __ ] sick
and it was fun it was that's casually
48 hours it gets if you when you get
into poker you get in oh god just
following the story it's like getting
into gaming right like you have your
like group that you go on and you
[ __ ] play call of duty or whatever
with and you just go in marathons right
and then um so one of my buddies in the
group
stole money from another buddy
blew like 80 grand of it
whatever it was that's a big detail
because he was thinking he was thinking
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna come up
really hard and then bring it back into
the account and like make everybody
happy that's what everybody always
thinks right it's the best it's it's the
most dj [ __ ] ever and after that it just
left a bad taste in all of our mouths
and then like it kind of broke up the
group so then now it's like you know i
don't want to go there by myself
and then life changed and jk started
really picking up at that time so then
like we were doing like four or five
different channels and just there was no
more time for poker
so i really got into it we used to have
poker games here we used to have jk
poker nights um and none of you guys
were part of that it was kind of shame
but then
a lot of youtubers would come through
you know
and then we would have different tables
and do tournaments that [ __ ] was really
[ __ ] fun you guys threw an illegal
gambling racketeering basically in the
state of california allegedly
basically
admitted here live on jk news yeah more
elections someone signed an nda what's
up
what's the statute on that i don't know
because they can't even prove it
happened
but yeah that was really fun like and
then a lot yeah a lot of you youtubers
came whatever whatever so then after
that i just several years went by and
then after i played like it was never
the [ __ ] same again and when you play
just like your friends it's much
different from going to the casinos from
the casinos you can do whatever the [ __ ]
you want and you don't feel bad but from
your friends and then you can't be as
aggressive with your friends it's
different it's like playing mafia
but like you want to play with strangers
because you don't know their play
everything and you can take their money
and not feel bad about it
and then i was telling nikki this
because she wanted to play poker a lot
and i was like nah and then later she
was like yeah i know exactly how that
feels i'm like yeah right it's better at
the casino and then um i started giving
her some of the books that helped me out
and i was like yo she's taking this
hella serious and then she got to the
point where like she just surpassed my
knowledge and understanding of
poker and i was like [ __ ] that's dope
and i was telling her the other day i
was like congratulations we were like
super rooting for you in the group chat
yeah you're living my like college
dreams because me and bart used to watch
world series with poker
like in our study breaks during college
and we just watch and be like man that's
so tight we should be on the world
series one day and it's like look
nikki's gonna go on
yeah he was crazy bro how did you even
get into poker [ __ ] something that she's
uh always dug
like like casually though she would like
play like house games with people like
she played me me and her have a fantasy
football league guys i've been in a
group with for like 12 years and so we
would play there sometimes and like i
[ __ ] suck at poker i don't understand
the game at all uh and that's kind of my
favorite thing about it is like if i get
an ace i'm like i just [ __ ] won the
whole [ __ ] thing yeah yeah
okay
uh but yeah i don't understand poker all
but she she um
just started to get really into it
during covid like she started to just
like really she was just playing like
some [ __ ] poker app on her phone
like it doesn't even take um doesn't
give you real money it's just like for
funsies yeah and then yeah after that
she was you know she's talking to joe
about you know joe's giving her some
books to check out
so really thanks to joe you know this is
all this all happened
but no no no you really actually were
awesome about that because she was um
she was taking it more seriously and you
were treating her like she was taking it
more seriously whereas like a lot of
people were just laughing because she's
like
you know pretty girl who like does
youtube stuff so like you know every
time she shows up at a poker anything
all the people there just think she's a
[ __ ] writer off yeah yeah yeah that's
definitely
so hard because today's video is brought
to you by feels
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you do not feel such as stress
anxiety pain discomfort yuck now the way
i integrate sp now the way i integrate
feels into my lifestyle is i have a
nighttime routine and if you have never
ever used cbd no worries feels has an
awesome little hotline that you can call
ahead and be like hey yo check this out
i've never done cbd how do i do this and
i'll walk you through the process but
this is my nighttime routine i get a
couple of drips and i go
put that in my tongue that's pretty
chill for me i do a little bit of
reading maybe some meditation some
stretching and i get off the phone and i
get ready to go to sleep and it really
helps me just have a nice eight hour
knockout session because when i'm
[ __ ] around on the phone maybe i'm
like reading emails doing whatever my
mind is like super super out there and
i'm just like full of anxiety and for
some reason i'm tossing and turning and
before you know it i'm watching three
guys in vietnam build huts in the jungle
and i can't go to sleep but thanks to
fields i have this nighttime routine and
it feels really really good and also you
can save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel at any time so start
feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com off
the record and you'll get 50 off your
first order with free shipping that's f
e a l s dot com slash off the record to
become a member and get 50 off
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping fields.com off
the record that's what i love about
poker is it's imagine playing mafia
and we all [ __ ] love mafia but
there's money and gambling involved
that's the best [ __ ] part of joe's so
hard right now
he's [ __ ] hard because like when it
comes to just table games meaning like
just um games at the casino right
there's no way of
maneuvering out of your loss
the cards are what the cards are so when
it comes out like meaning like you play
blackjack or you play the casino it's
just a statistics game it gets really
boring there's no real advantage when it
comes to poker
you can kind of
psychologically [ __ ] with your opponent
to make them believe that you actually
won
where they might have won they might
have had the cards but if they're also a
weak player they you could take their
money make them second guess themselves
exactly and that's the beauty behind it
is because the risk there's like a
double risk you're not just playing the
cards you're not just playing the odds
you're also playing players
that's
yeah dude that's me i'm like i'm like is
that good basically i just want a
million dollars
all your money is mine everyone folds
and i'm like [ __ ]
come on everyone all in right now
and no matter what any card that comes
out even if it's like it's like two four
five i'm like i got the aces i don't
wanna pay attention to the front of that
[ __ ] no no the river the [ __ ] what is
it the next guy just immediately puts
his [ __ ] car keys down on the table
[Laughter]
dude but there is so much to the game
that there's pots on me
i thought i didn't know poker before
and then now nikki's like
she's deep deep and then she the way
that she talks about it too it's like
when my brothers join the military i
don't know if you guys know people who
are in the military when they're around
each other they're just like talking in
code because they're like talking about
like semper fi you know yeah
purple hearts
i'm like honorable
yeah yeah yeah yeah morse codes that
it's kind of like the tubers right so
like crypto talk
like crypto talk for other people yeah
for sure but it's like tubers right like
tubers
when i first was coming up on on the
tubes i remember going to people's
houses and there they just did youtube
for a living i was like what the [ __ ] is
that
i mean like what are you talking about
talking about like analytics talking
about like yeah
yeah and they're all and you could get
paid for this stuff dude it's that and
it's like they're all tuber carnies you
know because they're according everyone
whips out the cameras and they're all
like okay you post this on this day
don't you post this until then because
i'm going to announce this then it's
like you guys know how that is with the
tubes but um
but with poker we just went to like this
guy's house because we're like in these
poker circles now and we were just at
this guy's house and everyone there just
does poker for living everyone there so
it was like you know hearing them all
talk code and you're just sitting there
like it's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah i'm like i can't believe this
shit's actually real but it's it's like
the same feeling that i had when i was
meeting two birds
yeah and they're really cool like it's
kind of like early tubes like like more
tight knit everyone's more supportive
and not doing the whole like i hope you
[ __ ] lose
you know what i mean like like that kind
of is what youtube turned into later
that's funny for poker though oh yeah
yeah yeah i know isn't it because you're
actually [ __ ] poker drama yeah and
well i'm sure it'll get there as there's
we'll have its attitude soon
but we but we met um some really cool
people in the poker community really
[ __ ] cool but our neighbor like right
next door to us is a poker legend
he won the world series poker before and
we've just been hanging out with them
for a couple months since we moved in
and so the fact that like the other
night
um i was doing my crypto corner and he
and nikki makes final table and i call
him and i'm like yo bro
he's like dude this is [ __ ] crazy
he's like this is [ __ ] crazy he's
like this shouldn't even be happening
he's like this
this is crazy he's like i was like we
should go down there right he's like
yeah we should we should go down there i
was like awesome so we both ubered down
there and then
like i'm surrounded by all these poker
guys i'm just some [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i barely even know what's going on
like i have to like i have to look so
like they're going like oh my god okay
lemo green just shoved shoved and i'm
like
the [ __ ] is going on guys you know what
i mean and then all these guys can just
see what's going on and they all go oh
and i'm like no
i would've did a royal flush
oh she had the nuts the whole time and
they're all talking this the whole time
steve's like she doesn't have any hate
like she doesn't have he's gonna lose
dude it's the best is the most confusing
but funniest thing you're like a
professional athlete's wife at this
point that's it dude i'm just standing
there i'm like go baby go i'm like what
happened
to usually know what the athlete's doing
though
i was like jessica simpson when she's
dating tony romo
yeah i'm like oh my god and they're like
jessica the game is this way and she's
like oh
he's more like the mistress then not the
wife because the wife is too involved
that's true he's the mystery mistress
he's the mystery you're a poker mistress
he's a poker honey
dude it's hilarious though and all these
guys i mean thank god
you know when i was there all the guys
there also do crypto or i would have had
nothing to talk about oh and sports
but yeah
damn vegas is like your disneyland it's
amazing dude vegas is hilarious dude you
know what i love though is that y'all
transitioned from like youtuber youtuber
to now being two different degens crypto
dj and poker dj it's amazing it's
beautiful follow the money dude that's
it it's got to follow follow money all
the way down follow the money all the
way like
to do poker like man vegas is there's so
many [ __ ] cars it sounds like she's
doing it full time too right she pretty
much has been yeah how many hours a week
do you think she's like actually playing
games over 40. we went to go eat dinner
just play and then she used to love
crabs right so we we used to go to the
honeymoon
no right after dinner she immediately
just went to the poker room and we're
like oh [ __ ] she's really into this [ __ ]
she's gotta go to work
do you guys even play craps anymore
we did with you know with ray a couple
times but like not as hard as yeah yeah
not really so to get understand the
scale of how good nicki is right
obviously she's really good for [ __ ]
what she did this past weekend right
yeah when she goes and plays regular
places does she just obliterate and just
take everyone's [ __ ] what just
depends because there's a lot of
variants in poker too so it just it just
i mean she's yeah man like honestly
because she has this little thing where
she puts in what she's done so since she
started playing poker her roi is like
[ __ ] absurd especially this past week
because of that win like her her like
her percentage is [ __ ] bananas right
um but yeah um she usually i mean yeah i
mean she's
only been in i think
a dozen tournaments she's final table
like six of them already like she's
she's a [ __ ] banana that her
notoriety is up is she gonna start being
like banned from casinos are they gonna
be like
hey
as soon as you guys walk in are you
going to see the guy
like and then they're going to go thank
you uh greens but uh that only happens
to blackjack they're just like oh uh mr
nikki limo green is over here so she
must be around that doesn't happen to
poker the casino doesn't care how much
you win from poker because they make
money regardless they make money because
from the rape so like players like if
we're all playing poker right we all put
money in against each other it's our own
money and in every single pot the casino
takes a percentage from that so
regardless if we win or lose they don't
care because they keep raking the money
um they don't like it when you make too
much money off of them so like when
you're playing the table games the slots
or whatever and then like especially
blackjack that's why like dana white
can't even play the casino
yeah it's because when you count cards
or whatever it's not illegal but um you
just know when it's favorable for you
so you can you can place big [ __ ]
bets and if you are good at controlling
your bankroll meaning like let's say you
can money manage yourself when you're up
you go all right i'm done for today and
you walk away
like eventually the casinos are gonna
take you but if you could do that well
right then you're like up a couple
million dollars
the margins actually at casinos are
pretty um not low but a couple of whales
can wipe them out for that year so then
that's why it gets really scary because
they're like oh [ __ ] this guy just won
three million and they're like oh
uh we need that back it's like in casino
when they make that guy fly back or the
delay is playing the japanese yeah
you're trying to leave yeah
yep and then he ends up broke right yeah
that's the game gotta stay on the
merry-go-round can't let him off yeah
but yeah no um
it's it's also funny too because she she
is such a humble person like going into
the world series she's just telling me
she's like i just want to be there i
just want to play there because she's
like been reading about it all year like
excited about all year so i'll just
can't wait to be around it and like in
it and get she got merch day one and
[ __ ] yeah and then now she's [ __ ]
getting sponsored by these poker
companies so [ __ ] cool it's so so
dope it's hilarious you sent that i
thought it was i thought when you first
sent in the group chat i thought it was
like right [ __ ] [ __ ] good
fake ryan
i was catching up you thought i was
making a joke article yeah yeah because
it was like because obviously it's your
wheelhouse you know so i was like
scrolling through and i was like is this
real and i had to go all the way up the
text messages to realize punchline i
don't know i don't know for context ryan
makes fake articles and sends them to
our group chat all the [ __ ]
he's a faker he's a big time faker he's
a deep faker of articles yeah that's a
very that's the joke oh she wanted she
won all this money wow that's hilarious
i didn't know the context until i read
the whole conversation somebody made
money this year i just got a friend
babylon b's gonna hire me for that one
[Music]
[Music]
you